parler de cette journée de manifestation
avec sophie tissier sur ce plateau
sophie tissier membres du collectif
d'éclat ta manif bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france 62e week-end de
mobilisation des gilet jaune en plaine
ou en plein mouvement social en tout cas
des retraites
vous sentez que il ya une convergence de
tous ces mouvements de colère on a vu
l'opéra garnier d'ailleurs cet après
midi également vous vous sentez soutenu
c'est magnifique ce qui se passe à
l'opéra ça montre à quel point toutes
les populations toutes les catégories de
population se dresse contre la politique
antisociale déshumanisante d'emmanuel
macron et ça fait chaud au coeur de voir
que voilà des artistes merci à eux
merci également danseuse de l'opéra
voilà tout il ya vraiment quelque chose
qui se passe en france
une colère sourde qui étaient tapis
depuis déjà de nombreux mois que vous
gilet jaune avait révélé aux médias
français en tout cas puisque vous cette
issue de la france de cette france qui
travaille et qu'il n'arrive plus à
boucler c'est un moment les gilet jaune
c'est tout c'est invisible ces personnes
qu'on n'entend pas qu'ils sont dans les
petits villages en province dans des
petites villes qui n'arrivent pas à
joindre les deux bouts
ces mères isolées c'est
mères-célibataires ses intérimaires tous
ceux qui travaillent dans la précarité
qui n'arrivent plus à vivre aujourd'hui
et on sait que cette réforme des
retraites va encore plus pénalisées
toutes les catégories sociales déjà
touché et aujourd'hui avec les gilet
jaune on est en train de continuer à
amplifier cette mobilisation
il est en train de se former une force
jaune je vous l'annoncé ce soir en
direct et je lance un appel à tous les
gels et jaune qui nous regardent
rejoignez nous il ya des gens de
bordeaux 2 lille de toutes les grandes
villes de toutes les régions qui sont en
train de se de se coordonner pour
continuer de battre le fer de la
mobilisation et au delà des retraites
on demande un profond changement de
système politique et on est en train de
mettre en place cette force jaune
strictement non violente pour empêcher
qu'ils aient des choses qui se passent
comme aujourd'hui en fin de
manifestation il ya trop débordements il
ya trop de choses qui continuent de
décrédibiliser le mouvement
malheureusement et nous on va continuer
d' amplifier la mobilisation et de
c'est de fédérer un maximum de gens il
ya eu lance cet appel ce soir de rallier
une force jaune tous ensemble avec
toutes les grandes villes pour
coordonnée des grandes actions aient
continué bien après la crise des
retraites
on sait pas ce que ça va donner on
espère que macron va entendre cette
colère et va comprendre qu'il faut qu'il
stoppe sa politique et qui retire la
réforme qu'il a jusqu'au retrait parce
que l'histoire de l'âge pivot on voit
bien que ça a été de manigances orques
orchestrée dès le départ par la cfdt
on l'a vu venir depuis des mois on sait
que l'âge pivot était là uniquement pour
faire un semblant de recul pour
permettre deux éléments du compagnie
éléments bien sûr mais un faux éléments
de compromis on sait que c'est pas la
question de l'âge pivot c'est pas ça le
danger de cette retraite c'est les
points c'est tout ce que derrière ça
enclenche et l'ouverture à la
capitalisation et des groupes comme
blackrock qui vont pouvoir se faire du
pognon surnom que nos nous relate
pourquoi une force jaune et non plus les
gilet jaune c'est pourra essayer de
renouveler on était là c'est déjà
l'automne évidemment c'est juste pour
pour fédérer autour de quelque chose
c'est léger les jurys pour se
différencier du mouvement gilet jaune du
départ et qu'ils vont retrouver la forme
originale du mouvement en fait nous on
veut être vraiment se rallier à l'état
d'idée plus agressif dans le nom la
force de la non-violence vous connaissez
ses gants 10 et il ya des tas de gens
qui ont théorisé ça pour rester
non-violents ça demande beaucoup de
force et de sang froid
ce que nous aujourd'hui ce qu'ont
dénoncé cette instrumentalisation de la
colère regarder l'agglo comportement d'
emmanuel macron qui est sans cesse dans
la provocation et de son gouvernement
qu'ils nous poussent à la faute
aujourd'hui encore on a toujours des
gens qui viennent pour provoquer pour
pour faire monter les l'agressivité
c'est ce que vous vous sentez dans les
manifestations sont dans les
manifestations tous les chez les jeunes
le voient qu'il ya des éléments qui
viennent qui sont d'un qui sont dans une
espèce de systématiquement de la saison
les casseurs est largement moins
régulière soeur il ya des jeunes qui
viennent qui sont qui les jeunes sont en
colère c'est normal mais on leur dit ne
tombez pas dans ce piège ou veut nous
amener
mâcon le gouvernement se sert de la
violence comme mode de gouvernance ils
veulent nous amener sur leur terrain
pour derrière réprimer on voit bien que
ce gouvernement ultra violent regardez
la répression hyper violent qui nous
assène guy dissuader d'aller manifester
d'ailleurs dissuade qui fait peur kiki
aussi énerve pas ce que c'est c'est du
donnant-donnant les forces de l'ordre
sont hyper agressive du coup les
manifestants sont agressifs les insultes
ça c'est tout est tendue et toutes ces
tensions amène à ce qui se passe ce soir
c'est à dire de plus en plus de violence
alors on sadr et rui le mouvement une
révélation est ce qui s'est passé hier
soir aux bouffes du nord le président de
la république a été surpris on est des
manifestants ont tenté une intrusion
bah oui ça montre à quel point le
président est détesté aujourd'hui ça
montre à quel point les gens sont dans
une totale défiance il on n'a plus envie
de respecter parce qu'il ne nous reste
que sur la rue aujourd'hui en tout cas
emmanuel macron ne respectent pas la
démocratie aujourd'hui donc les gens
sont très en colère après je trouve moi
cette histoire je trouve ça un petit peu
louche je ne comprends pas que le
président se retrouve dans le même
théâtre
quinze journalistes qui est très
militant qui est qu il a été arrêté est
qui et qui comme par hasard et arrêtez
moi je soutiens bay l'intérieur qui la
fille je me demande si c'est pas un
piège qui a été tendu at aboaf je trouve
un peu étonnant que les manuels mâcon
soient retrouvés dans le même théâtre
que tu as à bois parce qu'évidemment
vama on va la faire des hypothèses
n'importe quelle personne militante qui
se serait pas trouvé à trois rangées de
maquereaux aurait fait un twittos a dit
à maquereau cayla est évidemment vous
voyez ce que ça provoque tout le monde
vient et ai envie de voile a envie de
tout cas aurélie relais mais l'intérieur
et lui montrer un peu la pression du
peuple parce que les gens sont en colère
on a envie de lui dire emmanuel macron
mais bon sang arrête tes conneries
maintenant ça suffit
tu vois ce que tu es en train de faire
au pays 1 tu vois la violence que tu es
en train de faire monter nous arrive
même plus à demander des mesures là vous
êtes en zorro vous on est à demander
finalement le
un changement une dissolution de
l'assemblée ou non un accès solution de
l'assemblée nationale c'est notre
revendication avec les jets les jeunes
aujourd'hui ça fait des mois qu'on le
réclame
on voudrait la création d'états généraux
citoyen à l'assemblée nationale pour
permettre à tous les français de
reconstruire un nouveau renouveau
politique on veut pas attendre 2022
aujourd'hui le pays est à feu et à sang
il ya une colère sourde qui montent les
gens sont en train d'exploser la cocotte
minute explose donc il faudra battre les
cartes avec une nouvelle démocratie dont
on verra sa peine lors des municipales
peut être on espère que mercy pas les
listes citoyennes vont être très forte
et soutenue et en tous les cas que tous
les français se bougent aujourd'hui à
soutenir les grévistes c'est important
est que tous les français prennent
conscience qu'il faut se mobiliser
maintenant
merci beaucoup sophie tissier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france